it's an iconic American symbol the
National burnt depict for its long life
great strength and majesty and now it
could be under threat the bald eagle was
just one of the things protected under
the 1973 Endangered Species Act signed
into law by President Nixon it's been
described as the most essential piece of
legislation protecting fish plants and
wildlife in the US supporters say it
saved the likes of the grizzly bear and
the Florida manatee from extinction
the Donald Trump wants to expand oil and
gas drilling and to do that means
opening up the areas the protected
species call home I know the White House
has announced this to change the way the
Endangered Species Act is applied it
says it will ease the burden on
landowners and make economic growth
easier before only science could be used
to determine if a species should be
protected no economic factors will also
play a part what I would hope is that
each city each each community each state
in the United States takes their own
independent action to protect the
endangered species that are found in
their locality in a sense bypassing the
federal system just as they're doing
with the climate change situation where
cities and companies and communities
have taken climate change seriously even
though the US government appears not to
be the change will be lodged in the
Federal Register it takes 30 days before
it becomes accepted policy just three
months ago a United Nations report
warned human pressures could push 1
million species into extinction
worldwide and it suggested protecting
land and biodiversity was critical to
keep greenhouse gas emissions under
control environmentalists say polar
bears and Arctic seals could be among
those at risk from these new US
regulations
Allen Fisher al Jazeera